they've got the the spy the chinese spy
that was dating
the guy the eric swalwell swag yeah well
that wasn't confirmed that they were
dating or they were they were an item
for it wasn't even confirmed that they
were an item she was just helping with
like fundraisers
for a long time right yeah i mean she
had been around
helping people with fundraising here in
in washington dc
and i wouldn't say here because i'm not
in washington dc that's where i live but
um but basically when it comes to
i believe her name is fang fang and uh
or christine thing i think that's fun
sorry i apologize we had china
uncensored on the show and so we got the
correct pronunciation oh it's just
not sounding so nice nice um so fong
fong
she had basically embedded herself as a
uh sort of like a
a i guess not like a money
roller like basically someone who a cash
bundler yeah that's the best way of
putting it uh someone who would raise
money
for for different political causes and
uh then somehow
in the throughout the running of it all
eric swallow was brief that she's
actually a chinese spy
and uh then he basically had to several
contact with her but now
this just happened uh mccarthy has tried
to remove swalwell from the intel
committee
over the chinese spy story so this is
just from the other day oh wow i believe
it did
fail though they said the resolution
will not likely pass in a democratic
controlled house
think about how insane this is this dude
was being helped
a democrat by a chinese spy and
they're they're keeping him on the intel
committee it's like okay let them stay
in office
but don't give them access to intel
reports they don't care
they really don't care that's why i'm
saying man i wonder how many of these
people are in on the take
they know what's coming and they're like
many of them got to butter my bread you
know how many more spies are there
that's one
that we found out and now we know that
the institutions have been infiltrated
by the
basically by the concepts of of this you
know what 80-year plan that yuri
besmanov talked about it other other
people was like
they've been in here trying to divide us
and now they're calling it out
yeah because their plan they're
basically activating the plan well we do
know that um there was a chinese spy
that worked in senator dianne
feinstein's office
um driver i think so
um i have to confirm that so this is uh
yeah this is from back in august of
2018.
details surface about senator feinstein
and the chinese spy who worked for her
that's crazy yeah i'm pretty sure it was
a driver for her
yeah and uh it's not the first time
we've been infiltrated man i mean mike
pompeo was saying it earlier last year
about a year ago he said we've been
infiltrated at every single level
you name it yeah i mean it's it's not
surprising
at all i mean as you said when you're
number one
everyone has a target on your back every
basically every other country
if we're playing mario kart we're in
first place every country has a blue
shell
yeah yeah 100 well you know essentially
we were in first place i wonder
if slash when china does overtake us
maybe they already did and they're just
not going to let us
know you know what i mean why would they
let us know if they could stay in
if they could stay in their ranks
forever i mean and and focus on that
not that and also not to mention think
of the people who are actually and
not and this is something that people
you know think oh just because you know
the chinese they have to be surprised
think about all the non-chinese spies
that there are
i mean well they they they are they are
spies for the chinese government but
they're not right they're not
chinese but no but but also think about
when when kovit first started
and they had they lied to the who and
then the who ended up lying to the world
china ordered chinese citizens in
various countries to buy
personal protective equipment and ship
it back to china so they could use it
during the pandemics while they were
lying to us saying everything's fine
don't worry about it they were
they were instructing their citizens
there's these people weren't spies they
were just people who were living in
other countries for school or for
whatever reason
working at the behest of the chinese
communist party and
it makes me think of civilization the
game have you ever played that
it's been a while cool game um and i
think the chinese have overtaken us
militarily
but not culturally not scientifically i
don't think
no they stole all our intellectual yeah
they steal they basically are trying to
steal to keep up
um so they have overtaken us in some
ways
definitely militarily yeah they're
they're what's that thing where the
thousand talents program where they're
buying up these these college professors
offering them cash then professors are
lying about it getting caught and
getting arrested are you serious
yeah yeah yeah there's been a bunch of
professors now who
were secretly taking money from china
and then some of them got caught they
were not reporting this money so they
were getting grants from the us
government
and also getting money from the chinese
government and
effectively my understanding is they
were sharing this data
with the chinese party nazis think about
it if you were
alive in 1930 what side would you have
been on now you get to choose
would you will you take their money will
you take that nazi money there were a
lot of people in america who did
that's the problem is that there are too
many people who and this is
you know obviously because hindsight's
20 20 and we always look back
and think of you know if another
holocaust happened
how would we react to it
but that's the thing is like you know
everybody thought that
and i i referenced the syrian civil war
because that seemed like
an interesting you know that was a very
bloody affair
that uh has winded down but everybody
there were there were a lot of people in
the united states clamoring for
intervention
thinking that that was a that was
basically another genocide that was
taking place
and then we have this situation here in
xinjiang with the uyghurs being
and locked up in re-education camps were
seeing drone footage of them
on train platforms all in jumpsuits
blindfolded
shaved heads you know hands and feet
bonded up
and that is the closest thing i have
ever seen
in my life to what we saw in the
holocaust
closest thing and i'm still afraid to
compare that to the holocaust right
because of
the what that suggests and so
you can say that the you know they're
going to day concentration
camps that is like as far as that's to
the extent that i'll go
because there is there is these people
are being persecuted for
practicing their faith people being
persecuted for expressing different
political views uh for people who want
democracy
in hong kong and
you know all of our nothing will move
not
dark nothing no needle will move in the
right direction because
all of our amer all of the corporations
that were formerly
part of the united states have all sold
their souls
to china this time will never stand up
right
for it a lot of them not all this time
not all the ethno-authoritarians
it seems like they're gonna win it
seemed like that with the nazis too for
a while when they invaded france and
took
took control of france it was like this
is it man the british winston churchill
would just tell people
we're going to survive we're going to
get through this he didn't know he was
just gathered up
for sure china china's not stupid enough
to just
storm the borders of india necessarily i
mean the conflict happening on the
border with india is that
what was it they were fighting with
sticks and stones yeah because they know
there's going to be fighting but they
they know what propaganda is they know
information warfare works and they know
what will happen if the
of all people of the world demand
conflict it's bad enough to get the
concentration camps
but a lot of people still will be like
we're not going to do war it would wipe
out the planet if they if they stormed
into india with guns and took
took land then everyone would freak out
and say it's happening
it's happening anyway yeah we got to
stop it from happening so they know
better
they're going to infiltrate it's going
to be cyber attacks it's going to be
political warfare
like uh who was talking about political
warfare was that uh james was that
he had some great guests on this last
curt i don't know lot a lot of great
people talking about political warfare
and that yeah i think it was james i
think so and we're not prepared for it
we they're they're they know you gotta
you gotta be very careful about how
people view you
and that's why i think when we see these
these chinese you know officials
yelling at the us in a rant for 15
minutes saying that the us is
slaughtering black people they
know what they're doing they're trying
to show the world
they can make god bleed because then
there will be blood in the water and the
sharks will come
yeah i mean so eddie izzard the comedian
um although i i think i think that's
former name i apologize if i'm getting
it wrong yeah yeah i saw that recently
no but wears dresses from time to time
yeah yeah justin's in dragon ball that
might be he runs marathon that might be
the dead name oh
really did he change his name i think so
no i saw him recently and he's just
amazing he still goes back or she goes
i apologize i think he was either he or
she dresser but was not transgender
anyways
said something that was really prescient
at the time
um and it was it was sort of like
analyzing history and how
you know the biggest uh the biggest
mistake that hitler made was not
you know anything he had to do within
germany that was invading other
countries
you know because you have mao zedong
killed probably most people
any other dictator yeah joseph stalin uh
yeah pol pot you know
a number of different dictators the key
the key
theme for them and the reason they were
able to stay in power is that they never
invaded any other countries
yep and so china came close to it when
uh you had the korean war and they were
basically trying to impose
uh communism in in the korean peninsula
of course the united states fought back
at it went to stalemate now you have
north korea
and now you have china invading many
other countries with the belt and road
initiative exactly economically
exactly culturally look you can't
we talk about this all the time fourth
and fifth generational warfare
what what is the purpose of war you want
to gain control of resources and
territory
right or you want to stop a threat maybe
it's preemptive war but usually it's
about gaining access to a resource and
certain territory of some advantage for
your country
now how you gonna do that you're gonna
march in with guns and force people at
gunpoint well that creates resistance
and opposition right
people say no to that or you say ian
i'm gonna lend you a hundred bucks so
you can go get that that nice new suit
you wanted thanks dude and then we're
going to put compounded interest on it
so just don't worry sign here
and then what happens a week goes by and
i go where's that ten thousand dollars
yo me buddy oh and you're like whoa whoa
ten thousand
like yeah read the deal jimmy break his
legs oh
that's the game can i borrow another 10
000.
they're going to these people and
they're basically they're going to these
countries and saying
if you sell your country to me with this
deal
you will live like the king of kings and
then when you're dead
we'll take your country it's a win-win
isn't it and a lot of these people are
like works for me
the country will improve the lives of my
people will improve and then in 50 years
china will be in charge with exercising
debt and control over our country
sure whatever short-term gain long-term
losses
they are invading but they're doing it
smart this time they learn from us
the economic hit men which is kind of
out of this playbook they would do that
they would say hey we're going to give
you a big loan try and buy you out and
if the people refused
then they would try and assassinate the
leader and if they couldn't get to the
guy then they would declare all-out war
um it seems like the chinese aren't
trying step two
at all they're like they're very light
about this
slow long bribery they play the long
game
but but listen definitely you only need
step one
when they go to one country and say
we're gonna give you all this money to
help you with your infrastructure
and that country says no they go okay
well then we'll give it to your neighbor
good luck surviving and look wait wait
wait
that's that's the end of the game people
know that uh
in these countries they might have
pressure where it's like we've got
conflict with these different groups
with these different tribes with these
different
countries governments and so if china
starts arming and building up their
infrastructure how long will you last
that's how it's going to play out and
now you can see
with these chinese officials basically
making a mockery of the us saying
you're not coming from they literally
said it is wrong to say you're coming
from
from a position of strength people in
your own country don't trust your own
democracy you're slaughtering black
people
they smack down the us for 15 minutes
and what do we do we fight we have flame
wars we have culture wars
we are a silly people thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you